bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 l'aktu le journal de la
rédaction l'essentiel de l'actualité
locale et tout d'abord cette
interpellation elle d'un islamiste
attrape ce matin interpellations menées
par les policiers du raid avant une
expulsion
programmé dans l'après-midi vers
l'algérie il est soupçonné d'avoir
participé aux violences qui avaient
éclaté au lendemain de l'interpellation
d'une femme intégralement voilée et de
son mari après un contrôle d'identité il
aurait également tenu des discours
antisémite et appelé au jihad
un arrêté ministériel d'expulsion en
urgence avaient été pris à l'encontre de
cet homme
en septembre dernier il demeurait
jusqu'à ces derniers jours introuvable
un tout autre sujet la pose d'une
première pierre d'une crèche collective
privé à saint cyr l'école elle doit
ouvrir ses portes d'ici la fin de
l'année au square henri wallon situé
derrière l'école ernest bizet à l'épi
d'or
d'une superficie de 540 m² ce bâtiment
modulaire sera géré par la société la
maison bleue déjà implanté à elancourt
versailles ou viroflay elle cette
structure pourra accueillir 40 enfants
une moitié des places sera réservé à la
ville l'autre destinée aux entreprises
nous en parlions déjà brièvement hier
soir le parcours de l'édition de 2014 du
paris-nice et vient d'être dévoilée pour
la deuxième année consécutive la course
du soleil s'élancera du département des
yvelines plus précisément de la commune
de banque la jolie anthony rech et
jonathan vilma nous apporte plus de
précisions
pour la cinquième fois de son histoire
paris-nice s'élancera des yvelines
l'édition 2014 de la course du soleil
partira de mantes la jolie pour une
première étape longue de 162 kilomètres
avant de retrouver la ville de
rambouillet le département semble
devenir la terre promise du cyclisme
pourtant le peloton ne passera pas
devant le vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
oui mais on l'a beaucoup vu là pour
l'inauguration qu'il faut laisser le
temps je pense également à l'équipe ne
se roder un les l'inauguration d'une
sellerie l ai quelques jours bon voilà
il faut qu'ils prennent j'admire son
rythme de croisière
il ya encore des aménagements intérieurs
a achevé il y aura toujours quelque
chose de nouveau dans département des
yvelines dans le domaine cyclisme
indéniablement
grâce à cet outil performant au cours de
cette 72ème édition il n'y aura ni
prologue ni contre la montre une
première depuis près de 60 ans huit
étapes en ligne sont donc au programme
qui devrait sourire aux baroudeurs et
aux puncheurs
on souhaite que ce soit une course
ouverte avec des gens qui posent et qui
est une prime vraiment aux audacieux
c'est fait pour
je suis bien incapable de vous dire qui
va gagner parce qu'il n'ya pas les les
références classiques d'un chrono
différents
ils se jaugent et où d'une arrivée
classique en altitude il n'existe pas
non plus l'australien richie porte
défendra son titre
côté français sylvain chavanel 3e en
2009 aura toutes ses chances et les
espoirs lasserre boigny et bryan coquard
miseront certainement des victoires
d'étape
verdict à partir du 9 mars prochain et
puis c'est aussi du vélo mais cela
concerne tous les amateurs de deux roues
et pas uniquement les sportifs la région
ile de france vient de faire voter un
budget de cinq millions et demi des
dents faveur des projets d'aménagements
cyclables portés par les collectivités
locales
le département des yvelines est le mieux
doté avec un peu plus de 3 millions on
citera par exemple les 800000 euros de
dotation pour l'aménagement de 3 km 7 de
pistes cyclables long de la rd 30 entre
plaisir et elancourt les ateliers du
mercantour une association fondée en
1982 est long cours et qui propose un
apprentissage de toutes les techniques
de l'encadrement d'art anciennes et
contemporaines invité ce soir est rude à
fort bonsoir sa résidente des ateliers
du mercantour nous vous recevons
aujourd'hui parce que cela fait trente
ans que vous proposez une exposition
bisannuelle elle attire beaucoup de
monde cette exposition visiblement
environ 1500 visiteurs sur une semaine
la reddition va débuter demain comment
vous expliquer ce succès alors comment
expliquer ce succès je ne sais pas ça
s'est fait au fur à mesure des années je
pense je pense qu'on a un point fort
c'est la créativité
les professeurs sont très créatifs on
part du principe que chaque encadrement
mérite d'avoir une technique propre à
lui
donc nous ne faisons que des pièces
uniques je pense que la succès via un
petit peu delà de cette originalité de
cette heure je pense raison ce n'est un
petit peu cette exposition de cette
année quelques 300 modèles exposés
alors on les a comptés cette après midi
on a 320 répartis sur du classique du
très contemporain du ce que
j'appellerais dit ouf ou l'art de
l'encadrement et r quand même de rester
au maximum avec le respect de l'image
c'est à dire que le travail qui est au
tournoi presque un petit peu se faire
oublier
ben on peut faire tous
type dire n'importe quoi mais ce n'est
pas le cas on peut faire tout ce qu'on
veut mais du moment que ça respecte en
tout cas l'image il faut que l'image est
respectueux et voilà alors dire quelques
exceptions bien sûr quelques fois une
jolie carte postale avec beaucoup de
couleurs alors là ce n'est plus
l'encadrement l'image qui est la pièce
principale
c'est le tour mais là on s'amuse il ya
des règles très précises à respecter il
ya des règles en vous invitant il faut
être strict il faut être très très
stricte il faut être minutieux il faut
avoir un petit peu de goût mais ça ça
prend quand même bon c'est que ça mais
bon c'est palin et on peut faire mais de
la technique au départ ça prend c'est
une technique après on passe à l'art là
c'est beaucoup plus difficile
il ya des personnes qui n'y arriveront
jamais mais les professeurs sont là pour
expliquer comment y arriver
comment exploiter une image le goût bah
oui il y en a qui l'on y en a qui l'ont
moins mais on les aide chacun ses
propres goûts ceci dit souders fait un
peu difficile surtout on respecte le
goût de chacun
ce sont des élèves qui expose ce sens
que les élèves les 200 m dont 220 200
élèves chaque année fait partie sur 25
cours par semaine donc on a des cours
tous les jours s'adresse à qui sait ce
jour le cequr pardon justement à des
novices en plus et à quel rythme des
débutants y en a qui n'ont jamais fait
il y en a qui viennent pour se
perfectionner pour apprendre
l'originalité que dont on est assez
fiers
y'a pas d'âge si ce n'est que c'est à
partir de 14 ans a conduit plus terre
tahri voilà après arrivé à un certain
âge il faut quand même arrêter aussi
toujours à cause du cutter mais ça
s'adresse absolument à tout le monde et
je peux dire que tout le monde y arrive
on pourra voir des images de
l'exposition pour voir le résultat ce à
quoi arrive les élèves justement vous
leur apprenez quoi lorsqu'il arrive
quelles sont les premières règles avant
d'enlever règle avant d'arriver à ça
donc on commence par leur apprendre pour
le respect de l'image c'est la chose la
plus importante
ensuite comment calculer le cadre fini
en partant de l'image des marges qui
sont plus ou moins importantes qui sont
éventuellement classiques qui sont
toutes folles comme là parce qu'on a
grandi l'image
la technique de départ c'est un peut
compter et ensuite coupé ces quarts
et commencer à creuser les fenêtres à
découper à faire en profondeur à peindre
à faire de l'ombre soit enfin bon après
c'est beaucoup de techniques différentes
qu'il faut savoir utiliser aussi bien la
peinture menuiserie peut-être aussi
menuiseries dont les baguettes on les
fait beaucoup coupé dans le comex
mais aujourd'hui nous fabriquons des
baguettes en carton des chutes de
cartons c'est suffisamment solide pour
réussir un encadrement collées les unes
sur les autres c'est comme du bois
d'ailleurs le carton s'appelle du carton
bora et ça devient très très dur et
après on les parents les patines on les
passe à l'enduit et ça nous permet de
faire au lieu des baguettes classique
carré ou rectangulaire avec des formes
plus de liberté beaucoup plus de
libertés tout premier conseil que vous
donnez là quelqu'un qui débute donc ils
voudraient débuté peut-être alors
quelqu'un qui voudrait débuté par avoir
envie de le faire être un peu minutieux
est bon surtout pas se décourager parce
que tout le monde ya cru mais ça coûte
est ce que ça coûte cher justement de se
lancer ou est-ce qu'au contraire ça
permet aussi de faire des économies
si les cadres déjà tout fait dans la
nuance bon ça liban vous avez dans
certains supermarchés vous avez des
cadres très bon marché mais ce sont des
modèles fixe ce sont des choses fixe vu
le prix que prennent les encadreurs ont
fait très vite qu'on s'est connus sur un
trimestre ont fait 4 à 5 encadrement
c'est ça qui motive les jeunes des êtres
je pense n'y a pas que ça dans ceux qui
viennent ils ont envie de faire quelque
chose de leurs mains je pense quand même
que c'est une technique qui occupent les
mains et la tête
donc on déconnecte complètement ça
correspond bien ce qu'on a besoin
quelquefois aujourd'hui si on s'occupe
que de ses mains et qu'on oublie qu'on
pense à autre chose au fait une bêtise
donc automatiquement il faut être très
concentré
mais tout le monde y arrive donc je vous
dis une chose tout le monde y arrive à
faire si vous voulez voir l'exposition
elle se déroule jusqu'au 14 février ce
qu'il est possible d'acheter les
créations non parce que ce sont chaque
créateur garde ses créations garde ses
créations il a passé du temps à les
faire donc il n'a pas du tout envie de
les vendre ou très exceptionnellement
vous avez débuté quand comme moi j'ai
débuté l'encadrement il y a trente ans
j'ai enseigné pendant 25 années
je me suis arrêté j'ai laissé la relève
à mes filles
les deux filles qui sont professeurs
actuellement qui ont des idées
débordante c'est elle qui sont à
l'origine de cette exposition
maintenant je suis la présidente je gère
présidente des ateliers du mercantour
est un site internet aussi si vous
voulez vous inscrire ne serait ce qu'au
cours avant d'aller par la suite après
être allé voir l'exposition qui débute
demain et c'est jusqu'au 14 février
hôtel de ville de maurepas merci d'être
là c'est sur ce plateau culture toujours
le centre culturel de ben la barbacane
qui accueille dans son hall une étrange
d'installations interactives une machine
à explorer l est sont conçus par un
plasticien rodolphe baudouin pour la
compagnie inouïe aurélia de bissy et le
diwan sous ses airs d'engins sorti tout
droit d'un roman de jules verne
la machine à explorer les sons vous
invite à la découverte de
l'électroacoustique installé dans le
hall du centre culturel la barbacane à
ben cette étrange machine propose
diverses pistes d'exploration musicale
et sonore l'électroacoustique permet de
transformer des sons des bruits du
quotidien en un langage musical donc de
l'idée même c'est qu'on est tous
créateurs de quelque part de visites en
donnant un sens à des bruits donc là
quand on va écouter les cliquetis dénier
à l'allumage landes où quand on va
écouter les réverbérations les
résonances du lieu quelque part on
découvre que ce lieu qui est empli de de
plus ou moins de bruit de son devient
prend un sens deviennent musique et on
peut la percevoir comme tel
cinq dispositifs des couteaux tour de la
machine vous invite à l'expérience
il suffit de prendre un casque utilisé
les sons et bruit et les transformer en
musique
lenny caustique permet des auditeurs
qu'ils soient utilisés à une culture
musicale avancer ou simplement un désir
d'être surpris de découvrir que le monde
musical nous entourent réellement qui
sont aussi acteurs de ce monde musical
sans même avoir des compétences seules
fesci ou instrumentale en suis pour la
compagnie inouïe actuellement en
résidence artistique
cette installation interactive est en
accès libre jusqu'à fin mai et au cours
de ce reportage c'est une de nos
stagiaires de troisième qui s'est prêté
au jeu de cette machine à sons merci à
cyrielle je vous rappelle l'une des
informations du jour c'est
l'interpellation d'un islamiste attrape
interpellations menées par les policiers
du raid avant une expulsion programmé
dans l'après-midi vers l'algérie
il est soupçonné d'avoir participé aux
violences qui avaient éclaté au
lendemain de l'interpellation d'une
femme intégralement voilée et rattrape
donc et puis également de son mari
c'était à l'issue d'un contrôle
d'identité
cet homme aurait également tenu des
discours antisémite appelé à un jihad
un arrêté ministériel d'expulsion en
urgence a été pris à l'encontre de cet
homme a dès le mois de septembre dernier
il demeurait jusqu'à ces derniers jours
introuvable c'est la fin de cette
édition du 7 8 l'aktu merci de nous
avoir suivis rendez vous demain à 18
heures pour un nouveau point complet sur
l'actualité locale le journal qui vous
sera présenté par anthony rech bonne
soirée